this professor was giving advice to
students and you noticed that that
advice was either already obsolete or
would be obsolete by the time most of
them paid off their student loans nobody
come they graduated by the time they
graduated and what they learned from the
school would be obsolete and they would
not be able to pay off the student loan
with what they learned this is very
upsetting
I have a lot of friends I go to film
school and their one thing is like
they're like I wish I had spent that
money to make a film because they just
they're like we would have learned a lot
more and it's not you know anything
against going to film school but it's
just again if you're trying to teach
somebody somebody whose artistic how to
you can teach them how to channel that
into a format that's gonna be more
palpable to the masses but if you start
getting too much into like you know page
20 this has to have been on page 30 this
has to happen then you're like stifling
people's creativity in a way in terms of
how to break into the business everybody
goes down a different path I can say
without question that I've worked with a
lot of people who didn't go to college
so going to film school is not
necessarily something that you need to
have done but but I found it very
helpful because I I established
relationships with my classmates that
led directly to me finding work film is
a very specific world in which I don't
think you really need to go to film
school that being said some film schools
are like like a USC which is so great at
developing the community and like the
really the relationships that end up
being the thing that truly becomes the
the reason you spent all that money but
all the gear and the history of film and
the lessons you can learn about you know
how to direct the scene or whatever all
that stuff is in books and on the
internet and directors or actors giving
talks and it's just my opinion that I
just don't think films coolest necessary
for filmmakers but I don't want to
discourage someone who really wants to
learn that way
producing major and cinematography major
at Le film school I went to USC for
their grad program and production which
is you know kind of covers writing
directing producing to the basic film
school experience their trade school I
went to in East LA you know I was there
for about a year
it has different each semester is like a
different level of difficulty or like
more requirements someone for about a
year graduated with the two certificates
from there and um yeah that's where I
learned I mean a lot of the different
stuff I'm kind of like how to you know
buddy direct a film or be an ad on a
film just a director all different jobs
basically how to edit and all that stuff
and then I kind of took from there and
decided I really wanted to do which was
writing and directing my own material
the American Film Institute was a great
learning place great men whose partly
responsible for me being in this
industry is named Tony Villani and he
was the head of the American films so at
the time and Tony was a no-nonsense
person at that time was a cutting
process you paid your money and you were
not guaranteed to finish the two years
because every quarter in the basement of
the school there was a sheet of paper if
your name was not on it you were
dismissed and they were preparing you
for the reality of this industry of the
rejection and how no matter how good you
thought you were good to keep kicking
your game up and so what it gave me is
no matter what anybody else says about
my work and I see it in the theater I
know it could be better and I'm always
thinking about man I have one more day
or one more take with that actor or
whatever it is I could have done it
better so they gave you a realistic
understanding of the industry and
prepared you for it pretty well
I think what every school does it sent
you out there with hopes and dreams it
tells you that it's not going to be easy
but they really don't tell you how hard
it's really gonna be because I think
they don't want to discourage you from
because it's like it's a beast if you're
in film school look to your left look to
your right these are the people you're
gonna be working with in your career and
so you want to treat your classmates
well I mean you should do that just as a
human being but in terms of business
savvy you have to remember that they
have aspirations just like you do and so
not all of them but many of them will
succeed and they'll be gateways for to
help you get a job somewhere they
somebody's going to succeed before you
and then they're gonna move on to their
next job and somebody's gonna need to
replace them having a good relationship
with them is a good idea I also tell my
students when you go in and have a
meeting with somebody let's say you get
a pitch meeting somewhere or an
interview whatever the situation is be
nice to the receptionist be nice to the
assistants because they're gonna be
executives in a few years and they're
gonna remember how you treated them when
they weren't quote important and so it's
just been my experience you know I've
been around the business in one way or
another for 40 years now and I still run
into people that I had interactions with
when I was a production assistant or
that at different phases of my career
and it's you can't go wrong being decent
to other people one of the biggest
things about film school is that it
automatically brings together
collaborators because your class is
another 30 kids that are also doing the
same thing and so the contacts you meet
the fellow filmmaking teams that you
meet I mean some of the people that I
know made connections back then that are
still working together today on shoots
DPS that shot directors projects or
producers that are working with
directors so the partnerships that you
make in school end up
you know sometimes being really solid
forever I mean it's like it's like an
automatic friendship maker basically you
know you put together with all these
other people that are around the same
age and you're all wanting to make the
same thing to do the same thing to work
on movies so it's uh you know I would
say I would say like you know take
advantage of it because you're gonna be
in a scenario where you're never gonna
get you know twenty thousand feet of
free film again right so do it though I
was 10 years ago but free camera rentals
or free lighting packages or whatever
you get as being a student take
advantage of it and like make something
that you wouldn't be able to make out
you know otherwise I mean the biggest
part of it is just suddenly being thrown
into a group where you're you know you
have to make movies you you know you
have these deadlines set for you and you
have to produce yourself and and you
instantly have a circle of other
filmmakers that that you're doing that
could take you know if you're out in
another city or wherever it could take a
long time to find these people willing
to put in the same effort as you are
into these into making you know short
movies and writing and that's still
probably the biggest aspect for me of
was just you know looking for that extra
turn to be just jumped and thrown into
production and then and then you know
you find some mentors who are gonna push
you towards the kind of filmmaking you
want to make or the things you're
writing and so any yeah you've you know
USC there there's you know plentiful
there and I think the big things I look
at taking you know working with actors
is it would have you know the kind of
education that you get with people there
would be I think it would be more
difficult to get outside I suppose yeah
there's always like classes you can take
another thing
but I can't imagine you know that you
get the same level you know when you're
with the people that you're working with
I think I went to an NYU alumni
gathering which is one of those things
like you know I think all schools do
that that if you if you're a film school
and you come out to LA you know and
you're floating in limbo like you are
come to one of these events and all your
fellow straggle you know limbo you know
people trying to find a job will get
together and you're bound by this NYU
thing common thing and all I remember is
meeting of a former NYU graduate and he
said oh you should meet this guy because
he and even at that time I was kind of
worried about being dependent on a
studio or a networker giving me a job I
mean it already felt normally
competitive all I had was an was my
thesis film you know I wasn't going to
get picked to direct aliens or something
it wasn't that but I wasn't going to
happen and I started to think very I
started to think independently I was
like well look I've got to demonstrate
that I know that I demonstrate that I
can make a feature film to myself and
anybody else so I can't wait on somebody
giving me a fee money for a feature film
so I got to figure out a way to do this
and he was like oh well that's because
so many people are like well you know
it's studio I'm only gonna make 50
million dollar movies and I'm gonna
spend the next 10 years in development
and then it's like I never had the
patience for that I was and I guess I
was a bit of a pessimist I was like look
I'm gonna have to do this somehow am I
on my own or a realist yeah or yeah just
be or yeah and I just was like okay how
do I do that well I don't have the money
but this guy did this guy had the money
at least a modicum of money right on the
credit card and he had the the will his
name was his name was Mick wine-off
and and Mick was like I'm gonna do this
and I think he was suffering from the
same sort of fatigue that all of us he
had been coming as an actor he had been
trying to get parts and stuff and had
God had some success but he was getting
frustrated like this is going nowhere no
one's gonna give me a lead park so I
need to come up with a way where I can
get a lead part
well I'll produce a movie I'll pay for
it that'll guarantee me this lead part
and he had the strength and the he had
the smarts enough to put the thing
together he's the one who got Danny
Bonaduce but he still needed someone
like myself to write and direct it and
bring more cast and more crew and bring
that and so it was a good you know as a
classic collaboration he had these
resources but he needed this he needed
this from me and I needed someone to
bankroll my first feature so that's
that's how that happened we ended up
getting a grant from Panama ssin and
codec and we actually shot our thesis
project there on 35 mil and so it was
like kind of the ultimate because your
students so you can sort of like say hey
we're students and then everyone kind of
contributes to your project because
you're a student and so we ended up
basically getting several hundred
thousand dollars of expenses or
donations or effort or free camera
rentals or these kinds of things because
we were students so that was exciting to
sort of like get to make something that
you wouldn't have been able to make if
you weren't a student and I applied to a
lot of big film schools I didn't I
didn't get into a lot of them cuz my
standardized testing wasn't as high as
like you know what they should have been
they get into a big school so I think
when my first year of film school I had
a professor who was just so negative and
like such a bad gave bad vibes in the
classroom I was like you can't do this
and I told him I might idea for my
project and he goes you'll never pull
that off Jon because you'll never this
idea you have in your head and your 17
year old head you won't pull that off
and I never forgot that because I wanted
to shoot in a hotel and I had like I
wanted to do all these things and I
proved him wrong I did it and at the
very end when when I whenever he never
apologized for treating me like that but
my last meeting when the class was over
he had like a review I guess he said
well John you did it you pulled it off
and that's all I said you know I'd never
forgot it's one of those things you
never forget I would probably say do you
have permission to shoot here he didn't
name it like you have a permanently how
are you going you know do yep
have you talked to them what are you
gonna do someone gets hurt I would just
ask all the practical things that you
would ask you know you're gonna word you
if you're shooting up in Alton because I
was going to school in Carbondale are
you gonna use crew from the film school
if you are how are they all getting up
there or are you gonna use crew you know
I would ask more practical questions he
just said I can't couldn't do it instead
of trying to figure out how I was gonna
do it and be constructive about it he
just said I couldn't do it which is like
the worst thing a teacher could say to a
student you know and I remember his name
- because you don't everyone this guy's
name cuz you know I you forget all these
teachers name but I remember this guy's
name I don't want to say it but and I'm
almost thankful I'm almost thankful he
did that because you know that's I
didn't forget it you know I mean USU is
very production base you're still making
stuff I mean when I was there were still
adherent a little bit to the modes of
production of like a studio you know
what is a studio what is a larger shoot
crew wise look like what is what are the
roles you need you know and I don't know
that that you know I look back on some
of those kind of things and even I did
you know a thesis film there and you
kind of you know get thrown into this
world where you know it's almost
required to have a certain type of love
shoot that you know it's an equipment
heavy and and all those things and so
yeah it's really great to be on those
shoots but it's a little less realistic
for when you're getting out trying to
make you know say a super you know micro
budget movie and which is more of the
reality for what people coming out of
film school can make and so there was a
lot of that within some smaller classes
but it stills at least when I was there
was geared towards okay this is you know
the higher level of what we're gonna
push you towards and I'm not sure that
that even when it was happening it
didn't feel as relevant and so
that would be kind of the biggest
disconnecting you know it's probably
change
I would guess No so you were in film
school for what was it one month
yeah I'm basically a month I was I
didn't do too well in high school
although I got an amazing SAT score I
didn't study but I just did really well
on the SATs I was always a good test
taker but for junior and senior year I
didn't actually go to high school I
think I had like a record-breaking like
42 absences and I just never really
liked school I didn't like the system
and I didn't like learning about things
I didn't have any interest in I always
was
I tested highly gifted so they tried to
put me on like an accelerated track and
I just didn't want to do it I wanted to
do my own thing which was creative stuff
and at that time I was throwing raves
and so and and helping do PR for music
artists and that was way more fun so I I
used to pay people to you know say they
were me in class couldn't sign in on the
sign-in sheet so I went I I didn't do
well in in the last two years of high
school so I didn't have the grades to go
to a good film school like you know UCLA
or USC which is where I had wanted to go
so and my parents couldn't really afford
it either they had just gone through a
divorce and sold the house I grew up in
and stuff so and put both of my older
sisters through college so they told me
they wouldn't be able to pay it and so I
didn't want to grow up in student loans
you know like I didn't want to grow up
in debt so I went to Community College
and that was SMC Santa Monica Community
College and I was there for a month and
while I was there I was also working at
a sandwich shop which was my second job
I ever had and actually my last straight
job I ever had
and when I was working there I making
sandwiches and then going to these film
classes at SMC and you know the first
thing first day of class we're sitting
and me in the class we watch No Country
for Old Men and the teacher goes okay
and what did you guys think of it and
nobody raises their hand so I raised my
hand and I start talking about the
nihilistic themes in the film and really
getting in-depth into it and then the
teachers like excited it's the first day
and he's like yeah this is great what
are you guys thinking everybody's like
quiet and then like one girl slowly
raises her hand and goes I liked it and
everybody was like oh yeah I liked it
too oh yeah he was a that guy in uh he
was really good the Javier Bardem or
whatever and I was I was like um I was
trying to talk about like real stuff in
the movie and so I I I just didn't like
being there so they had a thing where
you know they assigned it in the
beginning of the year that by the end of
the year you had to either write a
script or make a short film or something
like that
and you had to write like a short script
and so I started writing a short script
and I really liked the short script and
I started writing it into a feature
script and then I finished the feature
script and my pure joy and I just
started hitting up friends of mine going
hey I want to make this movie all I need
is $7,000 $7,000 is all I need to make
it that's all that Robert Rodriguez had
to do el Mariachi I'll try and make it
work so I tried to get seven grand and I
ended up talking to my friend and then
business partner later Jared Cohen and
he gave me the seven grand to make the
movie and I remember I I just stopped
going to school dropped out to make the
movie because I couldn't deal with their
schedule and I was working at the
sandwich shop and I remember they called
me and they're like hey we need you to
come into work today and I was like I
can't do that you know I need to do
pre-production on this movie and they're
like well do they're like like is it a
real movie and I was like yeah it's a
real movie it's like a low-budget India
it's $7,000 budget and the guy laughs
and he goes well you got to ask yourself
do you want to make a small little indie
film or do you want to have a job and I
was like I want to make a small little
indie film piece and I hung up the phone
and never went back and I haven't had a
regular job since when I was there at La
film school several of our teachers were
actually working also and so they were
just off this set of big movies as a
production designer or had just had a
Mossel you know had just had an awful
failure at a big time movie and now
could tell you what they did wrong so
it's sort of like learning from people
that were like actually had the
experiences to talk about which is
really cool I remember my producing you
know instructor had kind of these horror
stories of how things go wrong and so in
producing class we kind of like would
learn about things like that things gone
wrong with nature and waiting for rain
and delayed days and problems with
actors and you sort of like oh wow man
what am I getting into here but you know
you push through it and you learn
various things you know cinematography
class just just um you know getting to
meet some of these amazing
cinematographers and talk about lighting
and just you know the people that know
their craft that have been in it already
for a decade and you kind of get those
experiences in school you kind of get to
see through their eyes like some tips on
what they've gone through I give the
students of varying advice one of the
things I do through my job as a
professor is I the adviser faculty
adviser for the TV Club and we bring in
speakers who are very successful most of
the time but in the late spring I do an
event called foot-in-the-door night
where I bring in the alums who are one
to five years into the business and say
tell them what you know now that you
wish you knew when you were in film
school tell him how do they go about
getting their first job because I can
talk about how I got my first job a
billion years ago but it's better for
the recent people to be there so it not
just for this event but in general I try
and get the graduating students to talk
to
the people who were a year or two ahead
of them and here are firsthand what's it
like out there what do I need to be
doing what should I be doing nothing
you're gonna find like reading or
watching a video somebody's gonna do is
gonna replicate going to making
something and so it's finding people
that shall mix up but that's the biggest
you know that's the biggest hurdle I
think for most people and that's why
film schools so very popular it's hard
to find those people that you can trust
and and who want to you know put the
same work that you're going to put into
these things it's yeah it's very
difficult to find you know and that's
why sometimes it's what you see people
spring up whether it's in other cities
or things and it feels like a little bit
of a movements because people have found
you know those those circles and support
each other but it's extremely hard to do
you know I don't think it happens very
often and so that's why film school will
still remain very popular you know
because it does that and but maybe you
know as more people want to get out
there and make movies on their own and
yeah film school is prohibitively
expensive yeah it'll be easier to
connect with like-minded folk when you
see everyone else's process and how they
put together a film and their style what
works and what doesn't so you can kind
of talk to them based on okay they'll
give you advice like hey you know this
this works for for this if you're gonna
do this certain way like shoot a film
this way you get a lot of advice on
different ways to not skyrocket your
budget I would say my talking to our
people obviously you learn from their
filmmakers and directors producers like
hey this is way you can save money
you're not spaying thousands thousands
dollars like some people who I've seen
some people come into the business and
they've never made a film not even a
short film I feature anything and
they're like hey I have all this money I
have this money I wanna make a feature
film or whatever I want to produce it
right I just don't know what I'm doing
so those people come in they start
talking our people and hiring people in
the business but they don't really know
that well and then they start giving
these huge budget breakdowns like oh you
need all this money for this huge crew
all these grips and gaffers and stuff
for this film you need all these people
you need all his money and they end up
making this film for all his money when
really they could have made it for 1/4
or they'd really need all those people
which I you had for me I've had like a
before I made my future I was thing
about working with our production
company and they had like this big
breakdown of this huge crew and I told
my my team of you I was like dude we
don't need all those people like I've
done this all my short films with a very
relatively smaller crew it's a lot
cheaper you know it's a lot better with
this I think you don't need all this
stuff and I talked to my scimitar for
who's produce and stuff and he was like
yeah we'll do this this this and worked
out fine
so I think talking to Eric filmmakers
with are in the business you can learn
from them on you know things will work
for making your budget ility small I
think it's a way to get your films made
inexpensively and to be in an
environment and with students who are
like-minded in in certain ways who have
who share with you
you know your time in the universe and
it can be very helpful to you because
they they have a perspective on what
you're trying to do as an artist that
actually no one else has because of that
so even the even the professor's or even
you know filmmakers who are well
established or famous who come to talk
to the students they're still talking
from a slightly different place or even
a tremendously different place than the
peer group so I think there's a great
deal that can be gotten from that and
you know in a short fairly short amount
of time and also the different film
schools have different ways of
specializing and how they teach film so
one of the strengths of NYU which is
clearly the one I know the best is that
everyone works on everybody else's film
everybody makes films and it means at
the end of that period of time you know
so much about production that I think
when you get out in the real world
nobody can pull the wool over your eyes
as to what's going on in production
well I remember at the time you know
we were in writing classes also we took
all the writing classes there to live
film school and one of the big things
was whoa you know you're writing kid
parts into your scripts here like you
want to stay away from that definitely
stay away from kids and stay away from
animals because they're gonna be chaos
on your set and like you want to have an
easy time here don't do it don't do it
and this was like hey this was told to
us but we were like you know we know
kids that are awesome and we're gonna do
it anyways and so in our thesis project
we ended up working with like a whole
children's choir you know 20 kids on set
and it was we we did
I would just never do it I don't it's
not like I wanted to learn in that way I
just wanted to to make videos and learn
by myself I'm just like when knowing now
that and around that time YouTube was
just starting to become a thing and you
could find a tutorial on anything with
your troubleshooting something or having
it didn't know how to work a specific
like editing function or a lighting
issue I just wanted to to teach myself
when I hit a roadblock
I just knew how easy it was to find the
answer on the internet and also not go
into debt and also I was very fortunate
to have my best friend was at USC and
was making all these wonderful friends
in film and television and music and I
ended up just kind of mooching off of
his experience really I dropped out of
school and I would hang out with these
dudes and start making videos with them
because they were so talented and funny
and that's it was just such a natural
like yeah I don't need to spend money on
school when I can just do it myself and
I have pretty much everything I need
with a camera and some funny friends I
don't think you have to go to film
school to to be a filmmaker I didn't go
to film school I would venture to say
that most people in the film business
did not go to film school they followed
a variety of paths in their lives that
said I also think there is value to the
college experience I think you it's a
time when you mature as a person but if
you really don't want to go to college
when you're 18 don't go get a job and
then see what see what that life is like
and how you'll have those experiences
and and maybe you'll be better off going
to college down the line or maybe you
won't find college fits with your life
life at all I think there are a lot of
choices on ways to go there but and I
almost go the other way I
I teach at a university and it's a
private university and it's expensive
and so on and sometimes I find myself
saying - there's so much competition to
get into a specific school I have to go
to this place you see it not just in
film school but my son has to go to Yale
or this kid thinks I have to go to
Berkeley or Stanford or something like
that and sometimes I think they take on
so much debt to go to a particular
private schools that it may not be the
right move for them there and I think I
think there are a lot of paths to
success and certainly Steven jobs found
a non-college path to success for
himself there or he went for a short
while to a school and got some things
out of it there I mean he's in the book
about him and he's talked about this in
the interviews he his favorite class in
college was calligraphy and it really
influenced him in choosing fonts when
they developed the Macintosh computer
and so you get all kinds of things out
of college that you don't necessarily
perceive at the time as vocational
training and I'm a big advocate for
people want to be storytellers to read
whether you do that through college and
taking other courses or just on your own
that's important but you do not have to
go to film school to get into the film
business and you do not have to go to
college to be successful there are
certain jobs where you do need a college
degree if you want to try and get into
the director skilled training program if
you want to try and get into one of the
studio training programs they're gonna
require a college degree but there are
many many paths to success the biggest
thing with with law school is law school
doesn't really it's not all about
teaching you the law the biggest thing
for me with law school was that it it
teaches you how to think and it just
rearranges your brain in such a way that
you can now approach any problem and
really be able to deconstruct it in a
different way to find an eventual
solution and so when I got out here it
was you know I didn't go to film school
and so now I needed to figure out how to
break in just like the you know hundred
thousand other people that do that every
month and but I looked at the problem of
breaking in and
in a different way I think I was
thinking about it differently because
the line of screenwriters that are very
talented the line of directors that are
very talented those lines are very long
and it's very competitive
they're all trying to go through a
couple different doors and for me I
wanted to try to figure out how to
differentiate myself in the marketplace
find a different door insight into the
industry and and I come from a really
interesting varied background where you
know I was I was a heavy creative writer
in in high school I played a lot of
tabletop role-playing games like
Dungeons & Dragons but not dungeons
dragons things like that they when I was
in college I wrote for the stage a lot I
invented board games to sell off the
licensers and manufacturers just through
this bizarre hobby then once I got into
law school obviously I had my my legal
training but also wrote and produced for
the screen while I was in law school so
I so understanding sort of these bizarre
skill sets that I have
I wanted to figure out how to leverage
all those things to help differentiate
myself in the marketplace to try to find
a different way in I quickly hooked up
with a couple people once I was out here
one guy that a comic book and a
technology background another guy that
had a music background he had 20 years
in the music industry and another guy
that had its branding and marketing
background so we all sitting around the
table working on a pilot project and we
thought okay how do i how do we use all
these other things that we have as a way
to help leverage our project in a
different way how do we create this this
pilot but at the same time incorporate a
boardgame component incorporate some
technology or a comic component how do
we approach it in a brand building way
rather than entertainment way and it was
really fascinating subject for me and it
was a fascinating problem to try to
solve once we started trying to do that
then that kind of got me to into the
area of transmedia but I don't think I
would have done could have done that if
I hadn't analyzed the problem
differently from a legal perspective
because if there's there's you know
the industry is is wildly complicated
but at the same time it's very similar
to the way it's been run for the last 50
hundred years and so for me just sitting
back coming in and completely fresh eyes
I looked at the way the industry was
built and the way it was constructed and
a lot of it didn't make sense then a lot
of the the path that most people were
taken seemed to be not a logical path
because it was a wreck running headlong
into the problems rather than trying a
different path to solve the problem
Einstein always said that you can't you
can't solve a problem with the same
thinking that caused it and so so I
looked at the problem looked at it
differently and thought we could take a
different path and so so that that got
me to where I am now which is using all
the tools that are disposal all the
mediums and platforms that all our
disposal in order to try to attack the
the industry in a completely different
way I believe you mentioned earlier that
you felt you'd learned everything from
film school within the first six months
yeah two weeks I mean once you know I
work the equipment it's you know I mean
it's sort of a separate conversation in
my view college in general like I think
college is a racket frankly unless
you're gonna be a doctor or whatever we
really you know does the world need
English literature majors and stuff like
that to spend a hundred grand it's like
just spend five grand you know get books
and stuff like that so film school I
think you know is valuable to a certain
degree but for me once I learned how to
work the equipment I don't need somebody
telling me you know screenwriting theory
and all that kind of for my
experience is the best way to learn how
to make movies is to a do them and be
watch them and you know listen to DVD
commentary so yeah once I learned how to
work the camera it was kind of like okay
I get it let's move on most people in
academia haven't worked in the real
world for a long time there's nothing
wrong with that inherently because most
professors that is there
their life calling and their passion and
that's fine but it's very hard for you
to talk about making a living when
you've made your living teaching for
decades right so if I were to teach a
class about how to make films and how to
make a career making films outside of
college I would start out with finding
things that are complementary one of the
first things that has happened with the
advent of the internet and with the
advent of all these new platforms that
are emerging at the beginning people
thought they could make videos and they
could edit videos on their own but
something people have discovered with
photography with video with graphics is
that if you're not experienced and don't
know what you're doing you tend to not
do a very good job so people now are
paying money for people to make videos
and tell stories about their brands
about their ideas about their concepts
and give them the opportunity to hire
people to do it those are great ways I
think to start out as a filmmaker
because you may not be telling the
narrative or documentary story you want
to tell but you are learning how to tell
a story and how to tell it effectively
for someone else which is an excellent
way to not only pay your bills to do the
thing that you got your education in or
that you aspire to be doing as opposed
to working at Starbucks or driving for
uber you're actively making something
that is a story whatever that story is
and what that does is if you save your
money you can run off to go make your
short films and run off to go make your
documentaries because you now have more
experience working with someone so when
you go to make your feature film and
you're answering not only to a producer
or a studio or a financier you're
learning to work with clients as a
filmmaker and then you're able to
understand the entire matrix of the
people that you have to work with
professionally I didn't I didn't do the
normal film school I don't I think you
just go and do it and you're gonna learn
itself you know I mean and but I always
the the psychoanalysis behind the films
I always think that it's super
interesting
first to create characters or just to
make any film because I think yeah it's
cool normal from school like we take the
camera and then go do it yourself and
it's gonna be your future film school
now the best way to learn how is he
hands-on just pick up camera start
shooting stuff I mean there's been a lot
of big-name directors that have started
I didn't once in a lot I think we're
dreaming to go to film school they just
started pick up a camera and started
shooting and kind of taught themselves
what you can your best film school
really is watching films because then
you learn how to up with you can see the
different shots they use for the film
and you kind of take from that okay this
is different shots and stuff so watching
a lot of films and then you know and
just pick a camera pick up a camera and
start shooting stuff but some people are
you know maybe better for the film
school may that they learn better me
essentially I wanted to go just because
I I didn't really just want to walk in
blind and start picking up with Cameron
she I kind of wanted some type of
instruction just to get started so it
kind of helped would learning the basics
and then from narrows it was relatively
simple once you want to basically you
just kind of build off of there you can
see their films watching their movies
and how I put stuff together it was
right after high school that when I
entered La Sorbonne as I I knew that I
wanted to do that but when you in France
when you finish high school there is no
clear way of just being a filmmaker when
so when you are and I think in the u.s.
it's kind of blurry also that's a gray
area I mean when you are graduating I
mean I mean nobody knows really how you
enter a film school or what are the film
schools are there I think that which is
kind of crazy because I think filmmaking
should be treated as a job as a real job
like other jobs and we should show maybe
the kids okay so you can go that way and
learn that and go into this school and
the craft there and I think that we it's
a common thing here and maybe in the US
and Europe and everywhere that will lack
a clear path to go and be movie director
I mean when you have a key to say I love
movies I want to make movies a lot of
the time they don't know where to go
which is that I think
a lot of people come out here with
dreams and I'm not saying is anything
wrong with dreaming but have some kind
of strategic plan that you mean when I
was coming here a black man big guy dark
there was no internet there was a no
YouTube Facebook people to look at like
me right now coming out here then create
webisodes for nothing and make him be
seen the network can be singing and they
can actually like what It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia start off as a webisode
then a DeVito saw it and now it was not
nine years so the thing is is that I
mean I always say to these kids what are
you waiting for
you're waiting for a system that is I
think what does I forgot the exact stats
it's AG but I think it's that the entire
union between five and ten percent work
at all annually that that ten percent
only a couple of a percentages make over
ten thousand dollars a year just go by
the stats so if you don't come in here
understanding the reality what you're
facing it's not the most pleasant
journey it doesn't matter if you're a
Georgia Southern student or a UCLA
student or a NYU student no college
students well that's maybe not true most
college students do not think about the
totality of the picture because when
they're in film school or when they're
learning how to tell a story or whatever
it is they're doing they get taught the
mechanics of it they get taught this is
a three-act structure this is how you
compose a frame this is how you run the
camera this is how you turn the sound on
and you learn these technical things but
no one and most schools do not teach the
practical elements of what it means to
be a film professional and that's a very
very different distinction and that's
something that unfortunately most of our
schools let students learn once they get
out into the real world and it's
something that should be taught in our
film schools
for they ever leave college because if
they want to do that they need to
understand how to see their career as a
trajectory not a short-term thing I tell
my students this is like when you go out
to LA it's like I don't even remember
the first like year-and-a-half of living
in LA just because it was so stressful
it was so right and I'm not trying to
scare anybody cuz this is the way it is
I mean you could I know people who come
to LA and they got a job in the first
month I was like I envy that but for me
it was like I don't know anybody I can't
get arrested right I don't you know all
those and that starts unless you're like
have her super thick skin which I don't
think a lot of us have I think you
developed that or you get crushed like I
think artists in general creative people
actors directors writers generally are
very sensitive people because you have
to be in order to do that thing like an
insensitive cold shut off from their
emotion director actor is not going to
do any interesting work I think so I
think most of us tend to be whatever
facade we put on are very vulnerable
frightened emotional people and when you
come and you when you put that up
against a business which does not give a
which is one of the most ruthless
you know doesn't give a
business and I know there are plenty of
other businesses but this place and the
other thing is that this business when
you are in Hollywood plays with your
dreams I mean that's the thing it's like
it's it's it's self it's a self titled
dream factory where if you hit the right
combination your dreams will come true I
don't think people go to even if they
get involved in a competitive business
that's not necessarily doesn't tap into
that part of your brain or about dreams
making your dreams happen so if you're
like in this state of vulnerability
anyway and it's all about if you do the
right thing your dreams will come true
it makes you a very fragile person so I
think most of us are looking for any way
to take a tiny step up from where you
are and I give this tip to my students
as well as to non students there if
you're looking
for the highest percentage way to try
and find work in the film industry learn
how to edit or learn how to do
post-production sound because there's
such a huge need for people to be
skilled at those tasks and everybody
wants to be the director or the writer
but if you can have a real bona fide
skill and it's not just a button-pushing
job they're genuinely creative jobs
people who are sound designers and
people who are editors you're gonna find
entry-level work they're not going to
hire you to be the editor on the next
Hobbit film or something like that but
there's so much production of webseries
of reality shows of everything you can
imagine industrial films and so on that
they need skilled competent editors that
you can find a way to pay the bills and
be learning more and more about your
craft every day with a student who is an
excellent editor at Chapman some years
ago who did not get her ideal job coming
right out of school she has she so
elegantly described it spent a year
blurring out boobs and balls on for some
sort of reality show but then because
she was getting better and better at it
she became the assistant editor on CSI
on the Las Vegas CSI series and did that
for three or four seasons and now is you
know a bonafide
working professional and so on and it's
because she had a genuine skill that she
could Bend out there in the world so
everyone goes to film Silicon to become
a director and I had this realization
about midway through my my sophomore
year at film school but God there are a
lot of really talented people in my
class and the idea that all of us are
going to get directing gigs immediately
upon graduation this is a little
ridiculous so so perhaps I should focus
on a craft just in case this directing
thing doesn't work out and an editing
was always my favorite part of the
process because I feel it's the closest
to directing you are you're you're
telling the story visually you are
crafting the performances you and you're
doing it from the comfort of an
air-conditioned room and interestingly
enough at the time
when I made the decision editing was the
the part of the process that required
the least technical know-how because we
were like I learned how to edit on film
we're using a steamed back a flatbed
editing system all you need to know was
how to thread it up and you could be an
editor being a cinematographer you had
to understand lighting and you had to
understand taking taking light meter
readings and film stocks you had to know
all of this stuff editing was really
just all about the art and it really
appealed to me and eyes that's what I
focused on and it's been very good to me
I don't get in trouble but I'll just be
honest
thank god I've seen a few exceptions
hard-working no excuse yeah there's only
there's two kinds of assistance that
come to me to work on my films one
they're nice kids smart kids you ask
them to do something they go do it then
they walk back and the Annis gives us
what you wanted other kid is the kid who
has observed you and your needs before
you sit and directing chair everything
you need is there give me something else
they run to get it and they run back and
they there before you get you get there
at six o'clock in the more there at 5:30
you leave at 9:00 they leave at 10:00
you see they they they they understand
the industry and the fact that they know
they need missionaries so once they
satisfy my needs I become their
missionary for the next job they
understand it and they get it but not
the majority I've had students who are
lazy and laziness is something I really
can't tolerate so
because of laziness I think that that
speaks of a sense of entitlement and
that's just not a good look in this
industry where you think that you are
title to something that you didn't you
deserve something because you know
wherever you think you are it doesn't
work like that another thing I like to
add is that and I'm speaking about my
school a lot of people come on and why
you thinking that because you have this
degree from this prestigious prestigious
institution in Yee or USC or ef5
Columbia in the real world they don't
really give a you know if you don't
have the talent that degree doesn't mean
a thing we're gonna come out of school
you should have your directorship the
film your deep you should have a real
editor should have a real if your screen
or I should have scripts so people want
people really want to see the work
you've done what's the best first job
for me when I get out of film school and
I think the answer is whatever job you
end up getting because your second job
will be a hundred times easier to get
than your first job when you're getting
your first job you don't have credits
and the students put together these
resumes that have all the student films
they worked on listed on it and nobody
in the professional world cares about
that and they don't care what your GPA
was or whether you received the
Chancellor's award for X or anything
they want to know what you can do and
they can only find that out when you
start working and start showing what you
can do when I was just first starting
out in Los Angeles the way people would
try to find work in editorial if they
didn't know anyone
literally you you there would be
facilities there are facilities that are
primarily editing houses and you would
just you'd walk around with a stack of
resumes and you'd knock on every door
and you'd see if someone would allow you
to talk to them for like 15 minutes in
hand a resume and maybe they would end
up needing someone
some point down the line and that could
lead to work sometimes it did usually
usually what happened to me is that I
was introduced to one person in this
industry a guy named Bob Layton who was
Rob Reiner's editor I'd worked with a
friend of his when I was in New York and
Bob introduced me to his assistants and
they in turn made some introductions and
and and through that I managed to get my
first internship and as luck would have
it one of the people I worked with on
that internship got a job working on a
movie that was paying and and she asked
me to come aboard and help out as an
apprentice editor and that got me into
the Union and once I was in the Union I
became eligible for a lot more work and
through those same connections IIIi was
able to land my first Union job on the
picture Boogie Nights so but you know
everyone's path is different
look if you're determined to work in
feature films you will get there
eventually I think there are many
advantages to not working in feature
films depending on what your chosen job
path is let's say you want to be a
cinematographer well the traditional way
to do this in the old old days was you'd
get a job at a equipment rental company
and you'd be the person who would check
out the gear to the companies who were
renting it and maybe you'd get a job as
a second camera assistant and then a
first camera assistant and so on
perfectly good paths and works there but
if you can add a film school and you
really want to start shooting things
yourself then doing webseries might be a
better option for you because no one's
gonna hire you
forget shooting Lord of the Rings no
one's gonna hire you to shoot an episode
of Hawaii five-o or even a reality show
there but somebody might hire you to be
the DP the director of photography on a
reality on a season on web series and
that might suit you better and then you
can find ways to work on slightly larger
projects and build your reel and all of
that there's just lots of ways to get to
the end point in the business I also
think it's important to not just get
locked in on no I only
want to do this event people say to me I
want to be a director so I'm not going
to take a job as an assistant director
because then I'll get typecast as an
assistant director and my response is as
opposed to being typecast as a barista I
mean you've got to pay the bills somehow
wouldn't it be better to have a job in
the industry learning about the industry
watching the director seeing how
different directors work how sets
operate then just saying no no I will
only step in when I am the visionary I
don't understand that attitude there's
two ways of breaking into the industry
now you know being a youtuber being a
viral person and that's something that
you know you it takes a lot of hard work
to be to have a video that goes viral
generally it's not something that you
can construct our plan it has to do with
slowly building an audience until you
kind of hit a critter but but the viral
hits that come from is like the come you
both are doing it intentionally they
come from like content producers as
opposed to like the the random video
situation it's it's it's a lot of hard
work leading up to that situation yes
it's like there's one way you can go the
new way the YouTube way the the Wild
West way of if you can you know show
someone who controls the money that you
can engage an audience and you can
create a brand for yourself
that's a good way to get noticed but you
have to be a slave to your content you
have to be adding new stuff constantly
which makes it really hard to do
anything other than what you're already
doing and it means that you have to be
doing you know vlogs or comedy or VFX or
something that's a very very narrow
focus which is not what a lot of people
go into filmmaking for they want to do
something a little more movies deep and
personal and it's it's this you know you
knew YouTube realm versus the old right
aspects group to try and get a manager
try and get an agent try and get
meetings try to get someone to buy it
which is more rapidly going away the
thing is that were caught in this whole
paradigm that
cannot do anything without the
permission of a system and if you
continue to think of it that way you're
right you're waiting for permission but
suppose you say I'm no longer waiting
for permission I'm going to create my
own opportunity and then be perfect in
the beginning but I'm going to refine it
I'm going to create strategic alliances
I'm an actor writer I know a starve a
starving director over there that guy
isn't worked in five years and he's
looking for something maybe he and I
well I know a set designer who's kind of
horror producer hasn't was fired four
years ago hasn't worked sentencing but
that kind of thinking it's in the book
that Seth Godin wrote called tribes he
says stop trying to do it by yourself
stop trying to do it by yourself you
don't have to walking the red carpet and
the glam glamorous stuff you talk about
I never really I never knew much about
that stuff I didn't care about that I
was I wanted to just make movies it's
hard to explain to someone that passion
or that need you just want to do it you
just keep and you want to do it bad
enough that you'll kind of like just
about do anything you know you and
you'll associate with people that are
feeling the same way that's what I try
to do like I kept my friends circle
passionate as well like the people that
I would surround myself with as friends
I would try to keep them the ones that
were also pushing as hard as they could
to get to the next level of things and
constantly making themselves better
constantly challenge one challenging one
another and you know shooting for the
moon and maybe falling short sometimes
with at least getting you know a little
further each time and you know it's it's
been tough sometimes because I you have
to leave some people kind of behind I
guess not behind but like you just sort
of veer off in different paths that's
been probably the most challenging thing
that's that's been one of the things
that sort of did kind of get me consider
maybe quitting at some point because it
was check it was challenging my
friendship sometimes and
you know that's tough for guy comes from
Ohio it's like one of the most important
things to use for friends and family but
I don't know I've always believed in
myself enough that I felt it I was doing
right doing the right thing and it seems
to have worked so far all of the choices
of course I've made some mistakes along
the way but my main sort of philosophy I
guess would be the word of keeping you
know surround yourself with people that
are like that it just really helps out a
lot you know those are my best friends
that right now some of my best friends
are you know guys that are still trying
to get to the next level as well and
it's inspiring to see that from them and
then hopefully it what what I'm doing is
also inspiring to them trade-off you
know but it's also yeah I think your
things that you can relate to with
people you can talk about difficulties
that are naturally gonna show up from
things like that you're doing you got
people that can relate to it at that
point I think that you're always finding
groups of committed ambitious young
artists and film is a collaborative
medium so you're always finding people
who are exciting each other igniting
each other stimulating each other and
collaborating together that is the
nature of film nobody does this on their
own
nobody does this alone and so I see now
students coming out of NYU forming
collectives now the Internet is a
content creation machine so there's all
kinds of opportunities for students who
are coming out of NYU were they've made
films together in class and now they
form production companies and they do
branded content that's essentially short
films that are showing their craft and
exercising their skills while they're
making that film that's going to be the
Sundance winner it's a really exciting
moment it's a daunting task to come out
of a place where this kind of thing is
not really done that often and to show
up to LA all of a sudden I have to
figure out where you gonna stand how
you're gonna stay afloat I was I had a
smart mother who made me save up enough
money to to be able to basically live
out here for a year without working I
just I was able to get work pretty
quickly so I had enough saved what you
know
that even if I was living a little
outside of my means just from being in
LA in general I could still survive for
a longer period of time I think that's a
huge very very important thing to for
people who are first starting out to do
that is to save up a bunch of money
before you try to come out here because
otherwise you end up chasing your rent
every day and it would be very hard to
commit to things that are gonna help you
get better even free things cuz when you
first start off that was how I got all
my jobs I would go on Craigslist and I
would just take gigs that were either no
pay or very very little pay just so I
can get to know people and meet people
because all those times people are like
you at that time and then if you meet
people that are like you and you're all
kind of coming up together you help each
other right it's not easy to just jump
on board steven spielberg's next project
you can't do that you have to have
friends that will ultimately become
Steven Spielberg or friends that are
gonna grow along with you so that way
you guys together can okay you have a
little team with you you know I mean so
that was part of my strategy when I
first moved out here was to at the time
it was Craigslist I'm not sure how how
effective that is today but I know
there's other things like staff me up
comm and places like that
you can try to get work and put yourself
out there and you know I would say if
you're first starting out for me the
best thing was to take free gigs have a
little my safe aside so I could do that
but then you have you let people then
owe you a favor too so if they get a job
that's paying they're gonna be more
likely to hook you up also I had a real
which helped a lot like I said before
I've been making movies since I was
eight so I had a reasonably decent real
for my age you know I was 21 right
there's no doubt here so I had a decent
amount of stuff on my reel for that that
time period and it was I think it was
impressive to an older group of people
who were maybe in their late twenties
early thirties that were in the position
to hire me for things so they'd be like
oh man that kids doing pretty cool stuff
already probably he'll be good someday I
think that's what their mentality was
and so they would hire me give me a
chance when maybe they wouldn't know if
they didn't see my work so that was a
big important thing too
I made a lot of my mistakes early on and
then whittled down the best of my work
into a real which I showed to people you
know it's two three minutes long there's
a lot of my early fan film stuff that I
did my friends and college but it was
good enough that I felt confident to
show it to people and I was actually
able to get my first semi tahg Rafi gig
that way
film called everyday Joe little short
film starred Jason Charles Miller
consequently he was later introduced me
to Tyler main just how I got the job for
compound the first job I got in LA was
from wasn't from him but I I worked with
him on that project I met him on that
project was a free vehicle II and years
later that's how I got compound so
that's what I mean like those people are
gonna move up you know at the same time
you are and then you have a good group
of friends that you can trade work and
war stories with you know I think that
what everybody's concerned about is that
there's the tsunami wave of content
there's an overabundance of content and
how do you emerge
I mean after you've been making your
YouTube videos what's next now back in
the 90s there was it was a lot harder
there were fewer opportunities there was
much less access films were shot on
celluloid there were a handful of
distributors only one or two festivals
that was interested in indie films so it
kind of winnowed out a lot but it also
meant that if you did something of
quality there was a clear route and
people would see you whereas today would
they find you it's the same question
people ask if the Beatles you know put
their music up on Pandora or whatever
would anybody notice them and that's a
real concern how do people emerge and I
don't have any answer I mean I think
it's about this generations don't have
to figure it out that's what I say to my
students it's on you now you know we got
either this point you're gonna have to
form your own future and they will they
will
I think this era is one full of
contradictions and the you know what is
that Einstein line or someone like the
sign of intelligence is to be able to
handle
conflicting ideas we're asked to do that
all the time in filmmaking now so I
think the logical approach for artists
working today is on one hand to be
incredibly prolific ubiquitous and thus
radically collaborative how do you have
a generative life today
when sustainability is such a question
right yet because the barriers to entry
the cost of creation and distribution
really have low been loaded so much we
have this other necessity just because
we can make something doesn't mean that
we should just because we can say
something doesn't mean that we should
that you want your ideas to be able to
percolate to become something that is
not just the collective unconscious you
know that that we're all thinking about
these things you know we all get the
same inputs but how do you get your
unique perspective on that in time is
certainly the best way to do that but
you have to say to yourself all right I
need to build my audience I need to
connect with a community I need to move
this all forward go go go with that same
sort of piece of like I need it to
really stand out there's so much this is
now the time of abundance it means that
the bar has been lifted for everybody we
have to reach that much higher and how
are we going to do that when we're also
being asked to be profoundly generative
you can have a lemonade stand in a
neighborhood and it's gonna be great but
if there's a hundred other lemonade
stands that pop up in your same
neighborhood you have to start looking
at how you approach your business
differently it's not just make how to
make better lemonade because there's a
certain point it's really difficult to
make better lemonade right I mean and
all these other people making lemonade
are gonna try to be trying to make
better lemonade and then it just
becomes very very difficult to try to
stand out in the lemonade business when
there's so many people trying to make
lemonade and so it's not just the
quality that has to improve which that
that's sort of a given we you also have
to just approach the the business of it
from a different way in order to
separate yourself in the marketplace
most people we most people say if I
can't make better lemonade then I'm just
going to do something else which I don't
think is a I don't think is the answer
because if if God puts you on earth to
make lemonade you make lemonade if
you're supposed to be a screenwriter
you'd be a screenwriter but you have to
approach it differently in order to be
competitive
I would watch a film with that mind
mindset and I would try to understand
what the directors choices were you know
I watched Terminator 2 which wasn't my
favorite movie for a long time it still
is one my favorite movie was like I'm
watching a million times still love it
but I would watch it and I would try to
understand why he made that why James
Cameron made the decision to shoot that
way why James Cameron made the decision
to have the actor do this or that or
move the camera here or what have you
and when I was growing up they didn't
have behind-the-scenes DVD documentaries
that gave away all these secrets I had
to figure it out for myself so it was a
little more challenging but it was also
something I retained a little more I
think is just an internal film knowledge
for Louise that I watched I would try to
I knew I'd loved a certain scene so I
paused that scene I'd watch it frame by
frame I'd watch it ten hundred times and
I tried to figure out why I liked that
scene and I figured out as I grew up a
little more and I started to have a
little more depth to my thought besides
just being an elementary school kid that
was looking at his friends I would I
would think even further you know an
easier 14:15 you start becoming a little
more aware of your world your your
awareness increases and
I would watch scenes that I liked when I
was younger with a new eye and I would
go home in I get it
this scene works because the rest of the
film works like I would watch heat right
Michael Mann movie when I favor films as
well there's that crazy gun fight bank
robber scene and about I think somewhere
in the third act and it's insane and
it's really really intense and by the
end of it I'm breathing heavily when I
watch it but it doesn't work the same if
I just watch it by itself i watch it by
itself it's very impressive it's really
cool but if I watch the entire film up
to that scene I have all this knowledge
in my head fresh of who these characters
are what their motivations are what
their emotional state is right before
the sequence and then we're let loose
and all that stuff is carried with you
throughout the scene and that I realized
it how important characters are early on
because I was noticing why I liked
certain scenes it was not so much
because I thought it was executed well
which was very true and I would try to
emulate that early on that was like the
best I could do as a filmmaker I try to
emulate the things I liked but in a very
small way because you can't really
understand it when you go so I would try
to like emulate shots and emulate
framing and emulate the way that pacing
was in the Edit and all that but I
wasn't quite getting it and part of it
was obviously where I was like a young
kid and I didn't have great actors and
fantastic production design or great
equipment but part of it was also I
didn't quite understand that other part
of it until later once I started to
understand that I became more interested
in and how that was done
how important
the actor is and making the character
come to life as well so all that stuff
kind of compounds you know when you're
doing your own homework I guess when I
was in college I would watch two three
movies a day even if I was just doing
homework and it was all in the
background at least I would have it on
the background I would look over
sometimes I could associate stuff I was
learning in class with a movie so have
you i when I read some when I read about
a subject now and I remembered studying
for it in college I remember oh I was
watching that scene and I heard when I
was student studying that part of this
topic so I have associations now with
movies like I remember that I was
watching this part of this movie when I
was taking that test or whatever and I
helped me do better my grades and stuff
because I was associating something I
really enjoyed or something I didn't
wasn't necessarily excited about at that
age but that's what I learned from I
didn't go to film school and was taught
these things from a teacher or professor
I'd did the work myself I I really spent
a lot of time when I was a kid watching
movies and just trying to learn from
them later on DVD came out and they
started doing behind the scenes and
people were you know the magicians were
pulling the curtain back and showing how
they did some of the tricks so I was
excited about that because some of the
times I'd be right about how I predicted
it that they would do things and some of
the times I'd be wrong so I'd make
adjustments to my thought process based
on that and and now I can watch a movie
and nine times out of ten I think I'm
pretty accurate about how when I try to
figure out how they did a certain thing
if it's done in camera sometimes this
fit CG or whatever it still working on
that aspect of my time I don't really
don't know how to do a lot of that stuff
yet I'm getting pretty good at
compositing but that's one of the things
that I'm trying to develop my little bit
more of a ability in because I feel like
it'll help me as a filmmaker to to have
a knowledge of visual effects a little
bit more in depth because then I can
make decisions on set with that
knowledge whereas up until now I mostly
been just doing stuff in camera well was
thanks Ursula that's so funny because I
hated sports so that's the only thing I
was doing is watching film and I was a
big big fan of 80s movies all the
committee committees
I've never my first real real film was
in 90
it was eat of Michel man that was the
first film that was just like whoa it
just knocked me out I was just like dad
sit film because just before it was all
about 80s movies and but I don't want to
do committees I don't care about that
it's fun I love watching but making them
not really but that's why I think the
idea rising it's very 80s with the music
and the tone the car you know the grand
national cars eighties car right the
music is very 80s and so that's my
influence but it was eaten Michael Mann
that was just like whoa I saw something
serious and then I'll always remember it
was eat in 95 with the music at the end
I was with Mobe the song that he did I
was just like wow that's the best song
in a film and then in 2001 with modern
Drive of David Lynch that's what really
show me mood the signature of a director
and that's what I was just like that's
where I starting making movies first of
all I screened films I have an eight
millimeter projector and I get all the
great classic Hollywood film directors
you know Billy welder and all the rest
of people that I admired and and I just
watched and learned from watching other
people do it and the same time that I
was doing that of course I was directing
in live television so I was getting
practical experience but so I was a
combination of experience and watching
other directors how they did it I
developed my skills as a storyteller I
was very lucky to have Sydney Newman as
my mentor and he would always say for
exact number would give you an example
one thing that I'm said in my mind there
was a scene where the Malays woman has
been terrorized by her mother and made
it regular kind of impotent as far as
men are concerned if you know what I
mean in relationship so she dies
and she sat in the chair that her mother
always occupied and delivered her
encomiums to her daughter and I thought
there it is the image of her sitting her
mother's chair would be see
to communicate and city said to attendee
nah you're not getting the full value of
of it it's - it's just an ordinary
ordinary bread-and-butter garden-variety
medium shot yeah you've got it so he
said to her four hands grasping the
thing but the same time she's Fred her
eyes always you know I'm so yeah you're
absolutely right first and I then
deliver then we did it
so the Sunport communicated both her
excitement but our fear becoming like
her mother and and her all the bad
experiences she's had with her mother
that they're slowly evoke by sitting in
the chair from which she always
delivered the bad news so that was the
kind of thing that you you know you
taught me the first time I ever shot
with the red camera I did not ever have
any experience of the red camera up to
that point one of the key questions that
they ask you is have you ever shot with
the red before and just came out like a
few weeks before that I was like oh yeah
of course you know I shot with it
numerous times like music videos and
blue I just had to make up something
because and then immediately after that
I was googling the instruction manual
and I showed up to set the next day I
even called my professors is like have
you guys ever got a hand your hands
under red camera like at Miami they're
like I don't even know what you're
talking about right now because it was
so new and I was like oh crap I'm gonna
I'm in over my head and I got so nervous
so I just said I got so nervous that I
over prepared so I went and I read the
entire manual front to back like four
times that night I had notes taken I had
like every possible problem that we
could have come up with I looked on
forums and see what people were having
overheating problems how you fixed that
blah blah I show up to set the next day
and I knew more about the camera than
the guy who owned it and I was like okay
I'm fine and that film turned out really
cool it was a little short film called
colony directed by a friend of mine
Kevin Hamid Anya sorry Kevin
I don't think I've ever told you this
story before but I didn't know how to
use a direct camera for a colony and I
ended up ultimately shooting that guy's
feature film junk which is now out on
DVD so a little bit of playing the game
I mean that's a Hollywood
you know story right there like that's
the kind of stuff I heard growing up and
that's the kind of stuff I learned from
reading Robert Rodriguez's book or you
just kind of like you know out here
there's no rules you can kind of make
your own rules I didn't have any
experience making a movie and so I
figured let me hire a pro DP who knows
what the hell he's doing and I did that
and and we shot for three four days or
something and I mean just the first shot
I was told by him that typically the
first days a disaster anyway but I don't
know if that's true but it took him like
four hours to set up this really basic
shot and I was like I guess this is how
they do it what do I know I'd never been
on a set before and after a few days of
this kind of stuff where it has to be
this way and the lighting and the crew
and everything I was like wait a minute
you know even if it does have to be like
this like I'm not comfortable with this
I'm running the show you're not running
it and we had you knows he had a bit of
an ego and and I do as well and so we
clashed and I said what about if we just
you know sorted and he was like no no no
so I said finally I just I said you're
done you're out goodbye
and the takeaway for me for that was if
this thing's gonna get up somehow
if it's gonna look shitty or if there's
gonna be something wrong with it I want
to be because I trusted my instincts and
I was wrong
rather than I didn't trust my instincts
and I just let this guy do whatever the
he wanted and you know and I think
there's something to that in terms of
the shooting the spirit of the shooting
really changed the vibe really changed
on the set because it was just kind of
like not like a punk-rock kind of vibe
but it wasn't so you know we're curing
cancer kind of thing and it's got to be
this dogmatic sort of that you know
and addition to which we were making you
know a thirty thousand dollar romantic
comedy it wasn't like we were you know
some serious period piece and heavy
drama in that so so yeah I just I
just shot the thing myself and the
credit the IMDB credit is Walter Brut
which is an
Robert law in my name I think one of the
most important things that you can do as
a filmmaker as learn the technology
because as it's becoming easier for an
independent filmmaker to you know even
just do a vlog with their webcam and
throw it up and become a celebrity on
YouTube you know that the takeaway is
the easier it becomes and the cheaper it
becomes to create your own content the
more an artist has to be a business
person a technical person at the same
time in order to be successful and I
think that owning a camera or having
access to a camera and understanding how
to use it understanding the technical
aspects of production is really really
really important and you can subsidize
your habit by getting jobs that involves
like renting our equipment that's what a
lot of a lot of people do also watch
movies are TV like whatever it is that
you want to do conservative media thing
yeah we meet people at films Cooper like
doesn't watch movies or didn't like
right I think you know for us YouTube
really took off you know when we were in
our maybe first or second year of school
and first of all USC at the time I don't
think this is the case anymore but and
it wasn't just USC specifically their
films oh yeah film schools were very
against putting videos on the Internet
there were a couple reasons why you know
there were you know if you're gonna be a
dumb kid and use copy written stuff we
don't want to get sued because of it but
there's also you know them not wanting
to launch you until you're ready a lot
of what film school used to be was an
arena for you to fail in private as you
were learning how to become a better
filmmaker but the reality is everyone
now must fail in public and it's it's
sort of an interesting world because you
want to be proud of your thing and put
it up and think it's good
but what if it doesn't land you know
that is something that in the past you
would have you know a school to critique
that and it wouldn't go anywhere and the
only time that anyone would actually see
it is if it was good enough to be seen
you didn't have you know in Internet
littered with the corpses of dead social
media and YouTube accounts that didn't
really work out and that's the reality
now and I think in some ways it's good
because not only is there some kind of
accountability but you know a lot
Hollywood has often run on a myth of the
wunderkind and the overnight success and
you know you the the common joke is you
work really really really hard for years
to be an overnight success and there's a
lot of that process that people don't
see and it becomes really discouraging
to people because they think like oh my
first feature screenplay isn't getting
sold you know what am I doing wrong that
you know Quentin Tarantino did right and
the reality is is you know people write
and write and write and write and write
but it just doesn't get seen and now
that you're seeing those those learning
processes in public I think it gives a
lot more inspiration to people that they
can actually get somewhere you know even
if you look at a popular YouTube channel
these people started somewhere if you go
back to their very first video and you
compare the very first video to the most
recent video if it's someone very
popular there's going to be a huge
change people don't just come out of the
woodwork perfectly and
I think you know under understanding
that is much more valuable than film
school I think that you know I I've met
with a lot of film teachers that don't
really know what they're supposed to be
teaching these days and I think that
what a film school can give you is still
valuable but I think that it's changing
and in terms of I want to be a filmmaker
what is the best way to for me to be a
filmmaker you know create content create
content constantly and show it to people
on a regular basis seek feedback for
your work change it when people don't
respond to it well and try to understand
why people aren't responding to it you
know iterate iterate iterate is
essentially what you're doing you know
the saying if you have to do 10,000
hours about something to be good at it
you do your 10,000 hours of YouTube
video and you will eventually reach a
spot where you're actually good at it
the things that I know now I don't think
I could have done then I think it took a
lot of experience and a lot of gigs to
get that knowledge and I'm glad that it
took that because I feel like it's more
engrained in my you know
style and just like instinct it's
something that I had to earn by working
so hard for so long I think I had a
blind confidence when I was younger that
helped me kind of push through things
that might have been discouraging her or
uh would have held me back if I dwelt on
too long and I'm thankful for that
I think I think that got me past a
certain point where now I can I feel
like I'm confident enough in my ability
that I feel like I really truly feel
like I can do just about anything that I
was asked to do as a cinematographer and
iyx I'm excited by challenges and things
that are tough now because it's you know
it's new it's fresh it keeps me excited
about what I do and I I still feel the
same way as I did back then because I
was constantly learning new things and I
think I'm I think there really isn't a
whole lot that I would have wished I
knew back then that I didn't know I mean
a lot of it I was already kind of doing
I got out of college 25 years ago and I
was really lucky to find a television
show called the 90s which was a which
was a documentary series that was based
out of WTTW in Chicago but it was a
national television show so it had a
very big audience and I was lucky to get
in on the ground floor there there were
only about gosh there only about three
or four other people making that show
when I when I started and so I was 22
and this was a really important moment
within documentary filmmaking because
hi-8 cameras had just come out then and
hi-8 cameras the quality of that format
was much better than VHS format like
there had been like camcorders that were
the qiat VHS they've been around for a
while but the quality of those was
really
low but high eight was was an affordable
and really high quality format and
that's kind of when I started and so a
month or two after starting at that show
I bought my own high eight camera and so
you know ten years earlier even five
years earlier in order to start shooting
for PBS you'd have to have a lot of
experience you might have to be in a
union you know you'd have to be older
quite frankly and I started shooting for
that show when I was 22 and so I would
go out and shoot something on a Monday
and Saturday night it was on PBS and
that that's pretty unusual that was um I
think nowadays maybe that doesn't seem
so strange because so many people have
cameras and access to distribution is
different than it was than it was then
but but to be on one of the three or
four networks four or five networks at
the time and to be that young I was I
was really pretty fortunate and I I
think for me I was just lucky I was
working with people who I liked and and
they gave me a chance to you know to
take a swing and I just remember really
at the time remember thinking you know
this is an amazing opportunity I mean I
really I mean I literally for a couple
of years I had that camera in my hand
almost anywhere I went I mean I carried
my camera with me all the time and I saw
something that was interesting or
someone I wanted to interview I had my
camera with me and I would start
shooting so I think that you know
knowing knowing what you want to do and
having a love for this in my case its
documentary films you know knowing that
is step one and then step two is just
find a good group of people to get in
with early or do it with your friends
it's it's it's really you know there's
there's there's there's two types of
people that I've met who really want to
do well in the
there's people who want like the fame
and fortune they usually don't do that
well there's there's the other group
which is the group that just really
loves movies and loves telling stories
and loves the collaboration of doing
this with people that you like doing it
with your friends those are the people
that that tend to really do well you
know because that they love it for the
right reasons so what would you say to
let's say a 22 year old man or woman
who's new in the industry and and wants
to do well I mean without sounding too
jaded not everybody's a mentor in an
environment and sometimes you're in work
environments that aren't that
collaborative right but you still need
the job you still want the experience
it's great on the resume
how does someone survive I think for 22
year old kids who are starting out or
even younger who are starting out and
want to get in to the film and
television business number one is is
know what you love like if you love
musicals watch as many musicals as you
can start to put the names to the work
start to really figure out I mean there
are people behind those behind that work
figure out who they are find them or
find people who know them or work with
them or or people who are doing work
like them okay musicals is a fairly
specific genre but maybe it's animation
maybe it's television news
maybe it's documentaries maybe it's big
Hollywood productions whatever that is
pinpoint who your heroes are and if
you're not able to work with them you
should be able to find work that's like
the work that they do that's number one
number two this is a very important rule
don't work with a jerk if you're working
with someone and they're lame bail on
them like I quit
goodbye and turn and walk out the door
because life is too short to work for
someone who's mean or you know really
impatient is not willing to share their
knowledge maybe they're insecure in
their own abilities and they don't
they're too busy trying to figure out
how they want to get ahead to stop and
help somebody else try to get ahead so I
mean you know what when you see it you
know but at the same time if you find
someone whose work you admire and
they're willing to sort of help you and
mentor you do whatever you can to keep
that job or to keep that position my my
first year at PBS I was an intern I mean
I had already graduated from college I
was an intern for the first six months
and I they were not able to pay me but I
loved working there so I got a job at
night I worked in a restaurant five
nights a week and then during the day I
work for PBS and you know eventually
they hired me and they knew they weren't
gonna get rid of me so they had to hire
me and then I was there about three
years then I went to grad school and
went went to the American Film Institute
and studied there as well keep at it
don't let one person you know don't have
one bad experience one bad project one
bad anything slowed you down because you
know the film business is unlike is
unlike most careers if you start out
when you're 20 you could have easily and
you could have a fifty to sixty year
career it's a long time you know
filmmakers oftentimes I think are like
like a good bottle of wine I mean they
they get better with age
compare that to say like a professional
athlete most of them are wrapped you
know they're washed up with that career
before they hit 30 they may go on to do
other great things but that's a really
short career filmmaking and storytelling
more and more is is is a it's a real
it's a real professional pursuit the
world needs great storytellers and it's
something that you can do almost until
the day you drop
so it's you have to be patient just hang
in there I also always have found this
true for my life and I think it's still
true the way I put it is if people are
paying me for five dollars worth of work
I try and give them ten dollars worth of
work and you know I try to see it as an
opportunity and sometimes I get students
who are more about well they're abusing
me and they're they're asking me to do
too much and it's you know yeah that's
the time-honored tradition of people
entering every business with you know
again doesn't matter whether it's the
carpet business or the entertainment
industry you pay your dues and if you
really love the the business you should
enjoy the paying the dues part you learn
by doing so edit everything you can why
not when I was in film school and I
decided that editing was what I wanted
to go into I made it a point to tell all
my friends that that I want to be an
editor this is what interests me the
most and I am and and so I started
working with their films and editing
editing as many films as I could when I
then made my way up the ranks as an
assistant working for Sally Mickey for
example she would give me scenes in in
like the movie all the pretty horses
that Billy Bob Thornton directed she
gave me some scenes to cut and it was
great that I like I would I would do the
work and I would send it off to her and
she would evaluate it and call me and
tell me this I was on location in San
Antonio while she was in LA and she
would give me her thoughts on the work
that I'd done and and tell me what she
had done to it and why she white the
changes that she had made and why she
and why she'd made them and it was very
inspiring to me it kept me going it it's
something that now that I'm in the
editors chair I try to do with my
assistants because I think there's no
question that it contributed to me
getting where I am I've had several
stages of realizing that it's still
happening
sometimes I wake up in the middle of the
night and I'm like wow I'm being paid to
make movies that's good
that's that's a good thing but honestly
that that one click never really there
was never really one click of the dream
is now a reality and I think it really
has to do with the fact that I guess
I've always known subconsciously that
it's all about just making stuff it's
all about just making art and you can do
that whether or not someone's paying you
to do it you can it's just something
that you do and I've always done it so
in a weird way this has been going on
since Mark and I were kids
we're just happen to be doing it at
studios and at HBO right now I don't
feel like I've made it at all and I
don't I don't know if anybody feels like
they've made it because you could easily
never do another movie again
no one will guarantee you a movie even
if you have a three-picture deal with
the studio they're not necessarily gonna
make it they're just gonna look at it
you know so I think you know it all just
comes down to you just have to make your
stuff and and believe in yourself and
and and keep doing it you know at any
level whether it's a 10 million dollar
studio movie or a $40,000 Kickstarter
project I had dinner at my house this
was like a year ago and like nine people
were there and the discussion was about
in your lifetime
out of all the people you've ever known
what percentage of them ended up doing
what they wanted to do with their lives
tonight percentage which three
three percent so when I look at my good
fortune all I continue to go through and
I've been through but I am still doing
it my age
what I want to do with my life and I
wake up every day and I want to do more
I do never want to retire no matter what
the pain has been I feel like I'm
blessed because most of my friends that
I grew up with are dead or if they're
not dead they retired from jobs they
hated that they did for 35 years or more
and they retire and they sit on the
porch and go on cruises and stuff which
is okay they never enjoy one day at work
not one day there's something if other
people can do it I mean they're shooting
a TV show in this hotel right now those
people working on that show that
director and those producers they're no
smarter or more talented than the
majority of people out here fighting me
and all the people watching this
interview or watching all the other
interviews it's just you know they got
the opportunity to do that that director
of knew the right person he got the
opportunity to go direct that TV show
you know the cards fell into place he
had more resources that's fine you know
it's just to mortal eyes that I got life
tattooed on my knuckles which some
people thought was stupid because they
thought it was like I don't like thug
life but for me it was you can't get a
restaurant job or a straight job when
you have tattoos on your knuckles and so
it was for me it was getting rid of my
fallback meaning that this is my life
this is what I'm gonna do and if I leave
a fallback for myself anytime things get
hard I'm gonna try and go to the
fallback and things get hard they really
do but as long as you don't have a
fallback you know that you got to keep
pushing forward and hustling and I think
I think you know I I talked with Wes
Craven once when we were working on
something and he he said that and I
really took it to heart that filmmaking
isn't judge
by how great of a filmmaker you are a
career in filmmaking is judged by the
ability to persevere if you believe in
yourself as a filmmaker and keep pushing
forward against all odds those are the
people that change things those are the
people that actually do and I want to be
a doer and I want to keep pushing
forward and I believe that you know it's
not always an easy road I grew up with
my dad being a writer he was you know
the head writer on pinky in the brain
and Animaniacs he won three Emmys and a
WGA Award and I remember sometimes we
had a lot of money and sometimes I
didn't get presents for the holidays and
it's because there's ups and downs and
as long as you can ride it out and
choose to persevere and go through it
you'll do okay I mean I just personally
believe if you want to be a film
director you need to just be a film
director and there's no limitations all
you need is a 5d you know you don't even
need a 5d ya iPhone I guarantee you if
you make a really fascinating script and
shoot it on iPhone people will watch it
and your next film will be bigger you
know it's I think the problem is when
people come in expecting to make
Apocalypse Now on their first go you
know it's it's probably not gonna happen
you know you need to start small and and
figure yourself out and allow yourself
the opportunity to mess up and do it
again if you mess up I think there's
something about our culture that has us
thinking that we can figure out who we
are inside of our heads but that's not
how it happens or at least that's not
how it happened for me I think the way
you figure so yourself out is by doing
things and by being in relation to other
people and as a filmmaker the way you
figure yourself out is by making things
and failing or succeeding and finishing
the film and showing it to strangers and
seeing how they react to it and how they
feel about it I think that's the only
way to to really figure out who you are
and what you have to offer because
if not it's just inside of your head it
doesn't it doesn't really mean anything
in the greater context of the world but
we all want to just do it in our heads
because it's safer